Chào các mồn tiền ngoại sao? Chính quyền tổng thống đường nên tròa m đang thuốc đầy một kế hoạch qua bình mới cho sải khách ra,
với một tiêu thảo gỡ thế bế tác kéo dài cho chức dụt thamas e-siren. Trong tâm của đi sốt là
ha mắt phải chả từ sông cho toàn bộ bộ mũm tảm con tiền. Chúng khi e-siren xuất lực lượng khỏi khách ra,
kế hoạch con những mạnh tụi bỏ phải chọn qua ha mắt trong chính quyền tương ai, thay bởi đó là một tư chế
khoảng lý tạm thời hài gấp dưới sự giám xác của cộng đồng của tế và cơ nước
á rập. Để sốt cũng bao gồm cái điều khoảng tảy thiết ra ra trong khoảng năm năm,
đồng thời e-siren có thể phòng tính một số tuy nhiên palestín để tạo nghiêm tiền.
Tâm thông trong cộng liều gió, có cú đầm phán tăng thằng với các bên ở diễn xa trong số 1 ngày,
bà sẽ còn tiếp tục truyền khi đạt đồng của thảo thuận hoàn trình. Đồng thời sang nhận,
là thông bao cho ha mắt phải e-siren ở tất cả các cập đầu. Để được có là bất đi cho thấy Mỹ muốn tái
đình hình lộ trình hoạ bình ở Trung đông. Chúng tôi cạnh các bên đều chữ sức cách từ giữa nữ tế,
tuy nhiên nữ tế vẫn chưa được tính nhất và quả chính đàn phản thân kiến sẽ còn kéo sài.